before you go i would never forgive  myself if i didn't ask you about  national treasure three is there any  news any anything in the works there was  always a  group of folks that were enthusiastic  and i'm thankful for that and i'm deeply  appreciated appreciative of that okay  okay but i i do i feel so it feels like  you're you're evading the question a  little bit that movie was the most  demanding movie i've ever made it was  more dialogue than i've ever had before  and i don't know that i could do it  again okay  i just i really need something here like  i just need a win national treasure 3  would  help you just help me get my life  together you know i would i would cut  back on my shoplifting i would i would  visit my kids more that's an interesting  statement in itself i think